hi Gary
this is yella from Amsterdam this is why
I need to be in episode 14 because our
biggest that soccer player called yo
hunk arrived we were the number 14 so
it's really important for us for our
Dutchman and here's my question Gary
I've read a book in 2011 called Think
and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill and that
book changed my life in a very positive
way I'm very curious about you Gary did
you read any books that change your life
in a very positive way thanks big shout
out to all the Dutch vayniacs the answer
to this question is pretty interesting
there's gonna be one of the shorter
dancers there's no that pre mentioned
book that I'm planning on writing if
it's my fourth or fifth or sixth book
when I hit eight books writing I will
accomplish a very rare feat which is
that will be the moment where I've
written more books that I've read I
believe that one of my core weaknesses
is my lack of reading books I just don't
read books it is stuff I've read three
business books in my life if you call
the Steve Jobs book a business book John
batali wrote a book called search about
Google and then well my favorite book
I've ever read was called nain it was
about the Supreme Court I've read like
seven bucks sorry